so common for content creators to to uh
to fans um keeps
hi i'm sweet anita and i did a video
with unilad and today we're going
through all of those comments
let's kill him attention seeking
i don't know what to say so fake typical
lad viable
so i have yet to meet a single person
with tourette's syndrome who hasn't been
accused of being fake
i didn't go outside i didn't make
friends i had my entire childhood and
all of my teen years robbed from me
because i knew this is how people would
respond and every time you say this
about me you're not just saying it to me
you're saying it to
every person with tourette's syndrome
reading the comment section to you
hoping that i'm getting acceptance
because maybe that means they will
so i'd really think about if you're
going to accuse random disabled people
of being fake do some research first
and if you still have that suspicion but
no proof it's better to trust someone
and
potentially maybe be duped maybe maybe
then blanket
out of safety some sort of safety um
abuse every single person with a
disability that you find
i'd rather be kind to everyone than
being
everyone instead and i don't know why
people keep making this choice
so how is she doing that whistle i want
to do that whistle
ah people kept i get that all the time
actually
uh i uh uh so there's two aspects to the
whistle
one is that it is a tick but it's also a
way for me not to tick
so uh my first tick whistle was
um but i also have the twitter whistle
where it's like and
quite a lot of people check their phones
on buses and trains it also
really helps me to stay out of prison
because sometimes when you're walking
places
like just so happens that a bunch of
school kids end up in front of you and
you don't want to offer
school kids a fisting can you give us a
blast sure what you want to hear
uh let's see
oh
[Applause]
this is of course awful but can we
please spare a thought for the guy who
got punched
in the deck he had it coming um
[Laughter]
and i have had ticks like i i punched a
dude
and he stayed with me for five years
after that so he was a champ
with the guy with the um who got punched
he did stay with me it was weird as well
i didn't have a
diagnosis i don't think at that point so
my first couple of boyfriends were like
i don't know why you're hitting me but i
still love you
i'm like oh bless them uh
um would smash a hundred percent
the real question is does she have an
only fans uh
i i wish i had a pound i wish i could
have like an oil tax where i could
like tax someone one pound for how many
every time i get asked for an only fans
because i'd be
rich i wouldn't even need to start one
major melons with a side of tourette's
i get a lot of body comments all the
time and i used to be really really
insecure and self-conscious
about everything about me and then i
started streaming and gradually gave
less and less of a
for two reasons and one of them is that
it's relentless and you kind of grow
numb to it and secondly after you learn
that people are into cake pop you start
to value public opinion a lot less
you're like well
some people are into some really
ridiculous things so and some people
like really approve of ridiculous things
but also hate people for really
ridiculous
reasons but yeah uh people are like how
do you deal with this and it's like well
i deal with this in public too like
people will literally walk up to me in
the street and say this
i've been getting this since i was nine
like a lot of girls do
so yeah if i stopped anything that i did
or got annoyed or upset or let them hold
my happiness hostage if i needed a world
without these kind of
comments to be happy i'd never be happy
um but as well
i guess literally as a woman if i go
outside
and breathe there'll be someone who
finds a way to fap to it
so the only way i'm ever going to have a
life the only way i'm ever going to do
anything i want in life
is if i stop caring how other people
think about it and how other people
react
even if it's with a boner anyone else
who just fell in love with her doing
this video
can she punch me in the anytime she
wants mainly due to it being very small
and normally found hiding behind a piece
ah that's incredibly good
marry me does she have a boyfriend i'm
not simp just asking because she's
beautiful
yeah okay so for those of you who don't
know what simping
means it stands for suckers idolizing
mediocre it's kind of a roast on both
ends
they're roasting the guy and the girl
because they're saying she's incredibly
mediocre
and he's going above and beyond for
someone who has nothing to offer in
return
usually it's when a guy thinks that they
can negotiate attraction
so they will give you time attention
they'll like every single
post on instagram from this girl they'll
donate every bit of money to
her and even if she has a boyfriend
they'll be convinced they're next in
line they'll never leave hope
um and it doesn't matter what you do
what you say they'll never stop pursuing
you like i've had people donate
thousands of pounds to me on stream
thinking that it will mean that one day
i'll fall in love with them
and what i explain very patiently to
people is
no you can't negotiate for attraction
like and the way i explain it to guys
specifically guys because most of the
people doing this are guys
is if a big burly gay man who's very
like big hairy chest very well built
muscular nothing wrong with being that
but probably not what a heterosexual guy
who's into me isn't he right
and if they do that if they go hey i
bought you stuff and i was your friend
and i listened to your problems and i
gave you all my money
why won't you sleep with me um you'd
understand
how weird and creepy it is and what if
you said no and they still kept doing it
and they're like have another thousand
do you love me yet do you love me yet
you'd be creeped out and so that's the
way i explain it to people
and it doesn't stop them um they don't
let go of their
they still keep giving me money so what
i do now
is i just save all of the money from
weird creepy inappropriate people
who donate money and are like how does
your ass smell though um
and i just put it towards like the
security fund so
i save it up for conventions and it goes
into a part
for a guy who looks very strong probably
with a gun if i'm in america who can
stand there and keep those people far
away from me
so it's very helpful and and thank you
do you think twitch does enough to stop
this kind of abuse to female streamers i
don't think this is a twitch problem
i think this is a loneliness problem the
thing with twitch is that uh
it competes with things like netflix
because
people watch twitch when they're lonely
we are the voice
in the corner of the room drowning out
the silence and we are someone you can
pay for an interaction
if you don't know how to make friends
and interact with strangers normally
and so a lot of lonely people don't have
social skills
and so when they have urges or thoughts
to occur to them they don't think about
whether or not they should say them in
the same way that
people who have social skills do and so
i think that
the problem is that we're living in a
more isolated world
not that you know big companies don't do
enough to
slap down horny people let go of your
love the part about complex ticks most
people only think that ticks are short
i've had to say
like do you think that that's
appropriate
wolf like behaviour and sushi what sushi
fun times
yeah i've had some really really really
complex tics
the problem with this is that when
people see something like that they
think it's fake and the best way i've
helped people calm down about it is to
say like have you ever heard of
sleepwalking
because some people sleep drive sleep
eat they get up and they do all sorts of
things in their sleep
so if you watch some sleepworking videos
you can see just how
complicated um involuntary actions can
be
in unconscious actions what
i actually adore her never seen someone
overcome such difficulties to shine
through
this bright her twitch channel is
incredible
and it's great to see her continuing to
grow and share her story
well that's really awesome that's really
encouraging i love comments like that
i think sometimes i get so bogged down
with like the angry comments and the
horny comments so common for content
creators to
to uh to fans um
keeps them fixed
give me a sec uh it's so common for
um content creators to get like 10
really awesome comments
but only really remember the one that
insulted their shoes
so i've ended up having to like take
screenshots of these like
sort of comments and putting them in a
folder whenever i feel a bit overwhelmed
and bogged down
by all the negativity on the internet i
go into that folder remember it is worth
keeping on so thank you to everyone who
takes the time to say something lovely
instead of something about my tits
i shared this with a woman at work her
daughter has recently developed tourette
syndrome
apparently her daughter only three or
four months into this nightmare
found the video incredibly reassuring as
it actually made a real difference to
her frame of mind even tips like what to
say to the taxi driver
she's going to use herself that's
awesome that's actually really great
i guess in a cool way it makes it worth
going through everything that i did
i mean if you saw the first video you
know i got bullied i got beaten up
i struggled with relationships
agoraphobia and depression
i had a really rough time but it makes
it worth going through all of that if it
means that other people get to skip that
now like that would have been so many
other people's story
and yeah i guess that's a really awesome
a really awesome side effect are there
any other comments or
things do you think we've missed that
you would want to talk about the comment
section has a lot
more power than people think i read a
study that said that people
tend to formulate their opinions on an
article more from
the comment section than from the
article itself
so people tend to lean with the majority
and how they feel in the comment section
so much more
so when you're leaving comments when
you're giving
a little piece of yourself to the world
just think about the influence and the
impact of that because
you know even the content creators
themselves are watching
and it's a way to spread the best of
yourself too so don't waste that
shut up [ __ ] when i started to try real
school
i had a lot of barriers i couldn't
explain why i was talking just shouting
over
the teachers i quite often insulted
other students
and it kind of all ended with me being
beaten unconscious by a bunch of sixth
formers